Hey youtubers it’s charlie, since we’ve
gotten past the doctor who christmas special
and series 8 is getting ready to film next
week I wanted to do a predictions video that
included some of the things that we actually
know already.
My plan for the next couple of months is to
do at least one doctor who video a week.
So sometimes when we learn new things about
series 8 it the videos will be about that
and other times they’ll be fun bonus videos
or q&A videos if you guys have a lot of questions
you want me to answer.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So what I’ll do in this video is start with
everything we do know, then do my top 5 predictions.
So things we know.
1 - Filming starts this monday.
january 6th.
They only have half the episodes planned out,
which is 6.
so they’ll finish the scripts for the second
half of the season while they’re making
this first batch.
2 - All the episodes will air week to week
without a giant break like series 7.
Raise your hand if you hated that break.
3 - there will be 13 episodes and possibly
an easter special.
No christmas special has been confirmed.
4 - Returning characters include the patternoster
gang, vastra, jenny and strax, of course clara
is returning for the full series but Alex
Kingston said she might be coming back too
with her classic spoilers line.
Remember her character’s relationship with
the doctor spanned multiple versions.
Not just matt smith’s doctor.
So it would totally be in keeping with canon
for her to interact with peter capaldi.
5 - The first episode will feature vastra,
jenny and strax.
6 - There is currently a blue peter competition
to design a few sonic screwdrivers for each
of them to use in that episode.
Can you imagine strax with a sonic screwdriver?
7 - Even though there are a few characters
returning steven moffat said in his own words
that he’s cleaning house.
Meaning a lot of the anacronisms of matt smith’s
era won’t be there.
I’ll talk more about that during predictions.
8 - The directors have been announced for
several episodes and include, Ben Wheatley,
Paul Murphy, and Douglas Mackinnon.
Each is doing two episodes, thus the 6 they’ll
start this monday.
9 - Currently the writers that have been hired
back are mostly familiar faces including,
Mark Gatiss, Neil Cross, and Gareth Roberts
not including steven moffat.
Who’s writing that first episode.
Writers currently still in talks are Chris
Chinball, Tom MacRae, Jack Lothien and possibly
Neil Gaiman.
Although he said doctor who doesn’t pay
very well.
So he’s a long shot.
And his last episode nightmare in sliver was
supposed to be a two-parter, got smashed into
one and everyone was disappointed.
So don’t expect him back.
10 - The premiere will be after August.
No official date yet but we could see episodes
by the end of august or september at the latest.
Time for predictions
First - the timelords.
They tried to contact the doctor via the cracks,
successfully.
That idea of them trying to bring gallifrey
back will be part of the larger narrative.
They’ll still be stuck in the pocket universe,
but because the daleks know what’s going
on now there’s the constant threat of resuming
the time war.
So series 8 will probably end with them still
stuck outside the universe.
But they’ll still be able to telephone the
doctor via cracks.
Second - Something else is going to try and
break into the universe.
If the time lords can do it, then so can something
really awful.
But because steven moffat is changing a lot
of aspects of the show, don’t expect it
to be a classic villain like the master or
another one of the time locked races that
david tennant mentions during the end of time.
3 - The doctor will leave clara by the end
of the series.
Meaning I expect to see a new companion during
series 9.
Right now both capaldi and jenna louise coleman
are only signed on for series 8.
I expect capaldi to stay for multiple series
although I’ve heard rumors his run will
be shorter than matt smith’s.
4 - There will be a new original villain.
Steven moffat created the silence during series
6 to be the main villains.
He’ll do the same type of thing again in
series 8.
Typically new baddies get introduced in the
first episode.
But since it will be a brand new doctor it
could be another cracks in the universe type
situation where the role typically given to
the antagonist is instead a new mystery.
and number 5 - The cracks will still be there.
Matt Smith’s doctor said that when he fixed
the universe it left a fundamental weakness
which is where the cracks come from.
He never fixed that weakness before regenerating.
So that will still be an issue.
It will allow both good things like the time
lords to be part of the story but also the
new main villain.
I know I talked about river song before I
did predictions, but since she’s already
gone ahead and teased it I think we can bump
her from maybe to probably to “spoilers”.
Let me know what you think about the idea
of them using a new original villain instead
of a classic villain in series 8.
Remember because of the cracks there’s still
the possibility that all those awful time
locked things could come back.
Like I said, I’ll still be doing weekly
doctor who videos going forward, if you have
specific things you’d like to see me make
videos for just let me know in the comments.
Right now click here for my christmas special
easter eggs and click here for my review of
sherlock series 3 episode 1.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!